[Musik]
was ist eigentlich pop ist das musik ist
dass literatur ist es eine kulturelle
strömungen der journalist tobi müller
vertritt in seinem neuen buch play
porsche repeat ein pop begriff der sich
auf drei säulen stützt musikgeräte und
körper er schreibt
pop ist nie nur musik sondern eine
erlebnis weise die erst mit dem einsatz
von technologie möglich wird im pop
bestimmen die geräte wie wir hören und
oft bestimmen sie auch wie wir uns sehen
wer wir sind wer wir sein könnten und
möchten
insofern definiert tobi müller pop als
hilfsmittel ständiger selbstbefragung
selbst justierung und
selbstvergewisserung
welche antworten pop auf drängende
fragen der zeit bislang hatte und warum
sich pop von politischen bewegungen wie
etwa protest kulturen inzwischen
entkoppelt hat darüber wollen wir im
heutigen faz bücher podcast sprechen
mein name ist khan schwanke ich bin in
unserem rating für die sachbücher
zuständig und darf nun tobi müller
begrüßen hallo herr müller guten tag
herr spanke freut mich sehr vielleicht
beginnen wir einmal mit einer
historischen einordnung
seit wann gibt es eigentlich das was sie
als pop bezeichnen das ist immer die
königs frage tatsächlich naja also
natürlich beginnt ob eigentlich mit
rock'n roll das heißt in den mittleren
50er jahren nicht versuche aber im buch
darzulegen dass die technologischen
voraussetzungen dass so etwas wie pop
tatsächlich entstehen konnte tatsächlich
sehr viel älter sind das beginnt
spätestens mit der tonaufnahme das
erzähle ich ein bisschen kursorisch im
buch tatsächlich wie die zustande kommt
und mit der quasi eskalierten
vervielfältigung das finde ich ist ja
tatsächlich entscheidend ob also wenn
etwas einsetzt was ich jetzt mit
klassischen kriterien wie
interessanter harmonik besonders
interessante rhythmik und so eigentlich
nicht mehr zu erklären ist wieder rocken
drogen etwas anderes einsetzt und das
sind eben tatsächlich die geräte die
vervielfältigung des singles
die sehr viel leichteren tonaufnahmen
die das tape ermöglicht werden also
durch tonbänder und so weiter das setzt
wirklich mit der 50er ein also wo
eigentlich die technologischen
voraussetzungen
und die stilistische
ausprägung einer populäre musik zusammen
fallen in der mittleren 50er und dann
beginnt auch puppen feuerwehr das gar
nicht möglich gewesen weil die
technologie gefehlt hätte ihr buch folgt
ja mehr oder weniger jahrzehnt für
jahrzehnt der technischen entwicklung
rund um die musik sie starten mit dem
tape und sie enden bei
streaming-diensten wie spotify und eine
wichtige these die sich durchzieht
lautet technologie ist nicht nur
hilfsmittel im pop sondern selbst
wichtiges instrument könnten sie das
konkretisieren vielleicht an einem
beispiel es fängt schon vor borken
tatsächlich nämlich erst thomas edison
dazu ton teste gemacht hat weil sänger
und sängerinnen auf tour geschickt mit
seinen jeweils neuesten fotografen
hinter einem vorhang und hat die leute
warten lassen wer singt gerade singt der
richtige sänger oder sind tatsächlich
das gerät und er hat dann die sänger und
sängerinnen angehalten die stimme so ein
bisschen zu pressen was wir heute
erkennen wenn wir zum beispiel
kommunalministerin oder so etwas wir
hören immer diese gepresster stimme
und wir wissen eigentlich gar nicht
haben die so gesungen oder sind es eben
die geräte die so geklungen haben und
das zieht sich durch die ganze
popgeschichte die rolling stones haben
mit street fighting man billige
kassettenrekorder genommen weil sie
plötzlich bei der aufnahme also 20
akustische gitarren schichten auf einen
billigen gerät um möglichst wie die
neueste technologie zu klingen wie der
kassettenrekorder von philips 1963
vorgestellt zum beispiel und das
wiederholt sich immer wieder dass
eigentlich trotz fortgeschrittener
technologie die popmusik versucht zu
klingen sowie die gerät dass sie die
geräte werden also quasi zu einem sound
standard da ich bestimmt wie pop musik
klingt und nicht umgekehrt es geht nicht
um einen quasi so mischen authenzität
muss wenn man so möchte also um eine
sehr getreue abbildung von realität
sondern im gegenteil es geht darum sowie
die technologie zu klingen sie bringen
einmal in ihrem buch das beispiel elvis
da wurde ja getrickst bei seinen ganz
frühen aufnahmen wenn man wenn man sich
die anhört dann hat und immer das gefühl
er steht in einem großen raum es gibt
allerdings einen gewissen hall effekt
und das ist ja kein zufall sondern
entstanden weil zwei tonbänder derselben
aufnahme mit minimaler verzögerung
direkt gleichzeitig laufen und so
entsteht dieser eindruck des echos gibt
es auch noch heute solche tricks die man
vergleichbar einfach produziert oder ist
das heute alles viel komplizierter
geworden
komplizierter und einfach kompliziert da
wurde technologie weiß meistens
tatsächlich digitale plugins sind mit
dem man auch quasi ehemals analoge
phänomene emulieren kann ganz einfach
man da ganz viele effekte darüber lägen
über was auch immer man kann auch
sämtliche verstärker eigentlich ziemlich
klang getreue emulieren außer sie haben
ein gehör wie ein junger hund oder eine
junge hin denn sonst ist sie sagen nicht
kaum mehr zu unterscheiden
es gab ja schon bei elvis eigentlich
alle effekte mit sogenannten feder hall
technologien in den gitarren verstärkern
zum beispiel aber dieser ganz besondere
nicht zu erklärende hall war wirklich
bei elvis eigenen ich glaube schon dass
gewisse leute die jetzt mit retro
technologie noch immer arbeiten jack
white könnte ich mir vorstellen zum
beispiel dass er noch auf so alten
landmaschinen kam steht dass die leute
das nicht wussten und das dann elvis zur
neuen plattenfirma kam also nach den
anfängen im legendären sun studio in
memphis bei arts ea die haben dann auch
so chöre hinten dran gemacht und so dass
das alles ein bisschen kommerzieller
klang die haben ihn daneben tatsächlich
in den flur gestellt des studios um
diesen heil quasi räumlich zu simulieren
weil sie einfach nicht drauf gaben
bietet seinem philips beiden studios
gemacht hat eben mit dieser minimale
verzögerung der bänder die diesen schon
sehr betörenden halt nix der stimme
natürlich daneben reproduziert haben
häufig ist es ja auch so dass die kultur
in der man sich bewegt mit dafür
verantwortlich ist wie musik letztlich
aufgenommen wird sie geben als beispiel
an den hiphop der amerikanischen west
und ostküste und wenn man den
miteinander vergleicht dann fällt auf
dass der eine lauter ist als der andere
können sie das erklären
auch das hat weder mit dem abspielen
geräten zu tun ich versuche auch wieder
ein bisschen kursorisch an der stelle zu
argumentieren dass eben zum beispiel in
new york also das zentrum das ostküsten
hip hops natürlich einfach kopfhörer
sehr viel verbreiteter bahn also man hat
ist nicht so viel auto gefahren die karl
couch oder gibt es doch überall in den
usa aber ausgerechnet in new york
eigentlich nicht so sehr weil die leute
dann doch zu arm waren für autos
entweder und weil man da einfach
software gefahren das sind öffentliche
verkehrsmittel in los angeles gibt es
zwar auch aber nie so gut ausgebaut wie
in new york und da ist die kakao auch in
miami übrigens ne und sagt nicht umsonst
mein ebay ist das waren einfach autos in
warmen gegenden wo man auch das heck
öffnen konnte und dementsprechend große
lautsprecher installieren dass das an
alles in ganz anderen wohl sagte
dementsprechend viel basslastige djs
haben anders geklungen also die
rezeption ist enorm wichtig dafür wie
man musik aufnimmt und ab mischt und ich
glaube fest und auf cristina pop haben
das ganz gut gezeigt hat sich heute ein
bisschen verschlafen weil heute klingt
ja eigentlich alles die südstaaten hip
hop weil da die anwälte der großen
industrie sehr lange nicht hingeguckt
haben was man damit samples machten da
konnte quasi im schatten der großen
majors etwas entstehen was die anwälte
übersehen hatten und jetzt klingt die
ganze welt so aber das war damals
natürlich anders in den 80ern und in den
90er jahren wo sich dieses ost west
verhältnis heraus geprägt hat sampling
ist ein gutes stichwort vielleicht
drehen wir einmal kurz darüber also über
die verwendung einer bereits fertigen
aufnahme etwa aus einem film oder einem
anderen musikstück für den hip hop ist
dieses verfahren ja absolut zentral aber
stellt sich immer beim sampling die
frage ist ein song der zum großen teil
aus samples zusammengesetzt ist etwas
neues eigenes originelles oder ist es
letztlich nur der beleg eines diebstahls
ja das unterscheidet gutes handling von
schlechtem sampling und das wetter so
schwierig dass juristisch zu klären was
wir da als gelungen und nicht gelogen
wahrnehmen die bildende kunst war er da
schon jahrzehnte diesen diskussionen
voraus natürlich mit dijon und dem
berühmten
final aber auch die pop art natürlich
die quasi comics reproduziert hat oder
andy warhol wurden diese geschichte vom
original das quasi verschwindet in der
seriellen reproduktion usw eigentlich
bereits geklärt aber es muss halt jeder
quasi kultursparten in der moderne oder
spätmoderne vergleicht das von neuem
wieder erklären heute das ist ja ganz
undenkbar dass man ohne samples arbeiten
würde es ist vielmehr so geworden ist
wie soll man sagen eine art statussymbol
geworden sind denken sie zum beispiel an
die kollaboration zwischen chelsea und
kanye west die mal einen song einfach
nur otis nannten das hatte dann ein sehr
teures sample von otis redding am anfang
was wenn die hunderttausende von dollars
gehen musste und die video haben sie
dazu ein sehr teures auto der marke
maybach quasi erst umgebaut und dann
demolierte also das statussymbol es
quasi nicht mehr nur das auto sondern
eben auch das sample und gleichzeitig
ist das ja quasi in fleisch und blut der
kopten
drastisch zu sagen übergegangen das ist
nicht anders geht dennoch es ist klar
ich meine es gibt mir eine reproduktion
von fremden sound zu man heute sagen
würde ja nee das ist jetzt schon nicht
so gelungen und das ist dann auch
richtig dass ab einer gewissen länge
dieser samples da die leute wie sagt man
minarette
entschädigt werden müssen und dass ich
meine berühmteste drama der hip hop
geschichte hat noch nie einen cent
gesehen für seine beats der taufe james
brown bei frank sommer eingespielt
hatten das wäre heute anders sie
schreiben immer wieder in ihrem buch
dass geräte des pop auf unsere körper zu
greifen was bedeutet das erstmal ist das
ganz konkret zu verstehen mit tragen sie
einfach oft sehr nahe am körper
tatsächlich wenn sie das mit den geräten
vergleichen mit denen sie quasi
klassische musik vielleicht erlernen
oder in die bildende kunst eingeführt
werden sind sie da viel stärker in
räumen unterwegs während dem die geräte
des pop quasi invasiv sind wenn man
möchte sie sind von anfang an sofort im
eigenheim vorhanden im kinderzimmer und
immer mehr natürlich auch wirklich im
körper drin also die kopfhörer die in
ear kopfhörer die quasi
im kopf drin stecken wenn man so möchte
das mobile kassetten gerät das man
herumtragen kann der walkman dem man
quasi in der tasche mit sich trägt die
vibrationen sind quasi auf der haut
selbst und das ist rein physisch
tatsächlich einfach ein körperliches
phänomen was glaubt die rezeption und
daneben auch die musik selber dieses
feedback ist der zentral für poppt also
das quasi die rezeption dermaßen wichtig
wird für poppen nicht nur das was im
kunstwerk selbst autonom stattfindet und
das ist das was ich meine die geräte
sind auf unseren körpern drauf und wir
müssen quasi nicht zu ihnen hin gehen
dass es sein quasi umgekehrtes
verhältnis zum was wir früher vielleicht
bürgerlichen kunstgenuss gelernt hatten
welche technische entwicklung hat ihren
eigenen musikgeschmack und ihr eigenes
musikhörverhalten am meisten geprägt
das war die tonbandkassetten tatsächlich
also die eigentlich 63 von philips auf
der funk messe in berlin vorgestellt
wurde die kam dann zu drei vier jahre
später also immerhin noch vor meiner
geburt kurz in unseren haushalt und zwar
mit zwei kassetten dies damals umsonst
dazu gab meine eltern hatten eigentlich
keinen pop die haben sich das gekauft um
fremdsprachen zu lernen dass auf dem
zweiten bildungsweg sozusagen weil ihnen
der erste aus sozialen gründen versperrt
war und das war eine kassette von bloss
in kaarst also diese
band aus chile aus den anden die in
paris gestrandet war und das war quasi
die erste pop kassette die ich zu hause
gehört habe und dann immer wieder so das
überspielen der kassette des eigene
kassetten kompilieren und dann mit dem
walkman quasi raus in die stadt tragen
bei mir tragen ich fast alles was mich
geprägt hat bis ich ungefähr 20 war 1990
ging eigentlich über die
tonbandkassetten dlp war natürlich auch
wichtig aber sie war sehr teuer sie
waren nur sehr kleine zahl vorhanden das
muss man auch mal sind opfer mangelware
der zugang war schwierig man musste sich
darum kümmern viel geld dafür ausgeben
sich immer zu jedem geburtstag und
diesem weihnachten etwas wünschen um die
sammlung langsam zu erhöhen und theaters
ein stück weiter diesen druck
vermindert er hat den zugang erleichtert
und die vervielfältigung quasi in gang
gebracht ohne tape wer pop für mich nie
ein zentrales phänomen geworden in
meinem leben es waren haben sie mixtapes
aufgenommen für freundinnen und freunde
mixtapes ja ich glaube bis sich so
anfang 20 waren der 90er jahren die 90er
jahre waren für mich technologisch so
ein bisschen ein verlorenes jahrzehnt
ehrlich gesagt wenn ich darüber
nachdenke
weil der disc maine kam dann so langsam
aber so richtig gut war dann doch nicht
dass immer ein bisschen gesprungen und
man konnte eben keine cds aufnehmen das
war irre teuer diese cd burner oder eben
brenner zu kaufen und bis dann endlich
steve jobs mit apple und itunes
2001 etwas angeboten hat das wo man eben
auch diesen kopierschutz umgehen konnte
der cds und eigene cds brennen konnte
ging das wahnsinnig lang also ich glaube
die ganzen 90 jahren durch gab es
eigentlich keine sinnvolle technologie
weil die kassetten verschwanden sondern
es mal ein bisschen alle hatten cds
konnten aber keine brennen
das ist so dass die luft der kälte
eigentlich und das ging daneben in den
drei jahren wieder an heute wissen wir
schon wieder nicht oder oder bringen sie
spotify playlist mit wenn sie irgendwo
eingeladen stadt bei einer flasche wein
ich habe das 1 2 überhaupt probiert aber
ich fand es nicht so richtig sechs ihre
ich gesagt ich habe in den 90ern fleißig
mixtapes aufgenommen und playlist noch
spotify noch nie erstellt tatsächlich ja
eben als mitbringsel taugt das hätten
wir nichts haben sich vermutlich sind
auch verschenkt oder an freundinnen und
frau ja klar
und an die jeweiligen love interest es
natürlich ja das ist natürlich die
höchste aller künstler also wie macht
man ein mixtape für ein love interest
das sind ja abend führen der diskussion
nicht weil tage zeit haben
adventskalender des verlages versucht
eine anleitung zu einem gelungenen mix
tape ich nie zugeben und das hat mich
einige zeit gekostet vielleicht können
wir noch mal auf steve jobs kommen den
sie gerade erwähnt haben nachdem der
ipod auf den markt gekommen ist hat sich
steve jobs ja für die shuffle funktion
also die funktion die songs in
zufälliger reihenfolge wieder gibt im
grunde genommen nicht wirklich
interessiert und sie sagen das war
kurzsichtig denn schaffe sei mit dafür
verantwortlich dass etwa protest
kulturen keinen spezifischen sound mehr
haben wie ist das zu erklären
wir sehen das ja jetzt wieder bei
spotify wir hatten gerade kürzlich den
protest von adele aus einer sehr
potenten player auf dem markt die gesagt
hat ich möchte ich schon dass mein album
in der reihenfolge gehört wird wie ich
zusammengestellt haben mit meinen leuten
ich fand dass er sinnvoll und schafe
ist halt die zufällige wiedergabe also
auch technologisch ist das ja eigentlich
bereits enthalten im englischen begriff
random access memories also war freier
zugriff heißt das auf deutsch das heißt
eigentlich dass ein digitaler player wie
ein ipod irgendwie sofort und wahl frei
zu greift auf das archiv und die ära des
archivs oder die kuratierte reihenfolge
eben nicht mehr respektiert und wenn
etwas quasi einen sinnhaften
zusammenhang erstellt hat eine popmusik
war es natürlich reihenfolgen
plattencovers die bilder die immer dazu
gekommen sind kein pop ohne bilder und
die digitalität hat erst einmal das bild
weg genommen die bandbreite war sehr
schmal man konnte noch nicht viel machen
mit bildern schon gar nicht mit
bewegtbildern das video ist ja auch erst
mal gestorben in den nullerjahren
tatsächlich und diese wie soll man sagen
kontingentierung oder diese zufälligkeit
die musiker erfahren hat hat tatsächlich
gleichzeitig dazu geführt dass versuche
ich ein paar beispielen dazu zeigen dass
soziale bewegung zwar noch da waren aber
keinen spezifischen sound mehr hatten
also musik hatte quasi diese avantgarde
funktion für auch immer wieder protest
des pop am see reaktionär sein es muss
nicht zwingend quasi sozial progressiv
sein sonst nicht aber es hat ja immer
wieder diese funktion genau da
eigentlich verloren dann kamen natürlich
auch soziale medien dazu die vielleicht
auch die sinnvolleren tools sind um
gegen soziale bewegungen zu organisieren
aber dieser gleichzeitigkeit fand ich
jetzt beim schreiben schon frappierend
also das gleichzeitig ein wahlfreie
zugriff auf das archiv stattfindet und
dann plötzlich nach der g8 in genua 2001
die letzten richtig gewalttätigen
proteste wo man noch sagen könnte ja die
höheren wahrscheinlich hardcore oder die
höheren wahrscheinlich so was wie rage
against the machine wo der manu chao
vielleicht dass das eigentlich plötzlich
egal wurde hat doch rost befreien das ne
wenn man quasi sagen kann ich bin gegen
dies oder das und bin aber jetzt nicht
dazu gezwungen diese oder jene musik das
kann man auch so sehen aber der
zeitpunkt ist schon
sage mal es ist eine korrelation ob sie
dann wirklich stimmt kausal wäre
vielleicht noch mal eine andere frage
sie schreiben ja auch die in der musik
falle die digitalisierung mit einem
diversifizierung schub zusammen
hängt dass direkt mit dran oder ist das
noch ein ganz eigenes fällt es schon
eigenes feld ich würde auch ein bisschen
früher auf ausmachen im buch nämlich
ende der 90er jahre mit der sogenannten
latin explosion dass leute ricky martin
oder auch shakira und andere plötzlich
sehr groß wurden und zwar vor allem
jetzt auf den us amerikanischen markt im
größten weltweit was davor undenkbar war
das nicht auch spanisch singen zum
beispiel dass plötzlich latin stars
nicht nur an ihren ehemaligen oder auch
herkunftsländer wie kolumbien oder
mexiko oder so groß werden sondern eben
auch auf den größten märkten der welt
und ich glaube das hat da er mit den
tauschbörsen den elegant zu tun gehabt
dass sie auch plötzlich gesehen haben wo
wir haben hier zugriffe auf diese musik
von märkten die wir gar nicht kennen
also dass das erst mal einer
kapitalistischen blog gehorchend auch
eine der marktforschung die früher so
irre teuer war sie kennen das vielleicht
auch von ihrer zeitung nicht mehr vor 20
30 jahren marktforschung wie viele leute
lesen das feuer toll was lesen sie genau
das hat man einmal gemacht alle fünf
jahres war irre teuer und dann hat man
die resultate sofort versucht zu
verdrängen
heute haben sie diese marktforschung
natürlich sofort frei haus hat aber auch
dazu geführt im pop zumindest versuche
ich zu argumentieren dass man hat eben
gemerkt hat wir haben hier eine klientel
die muss gar nicht alle aus den reichen
vorstädten seien die muss auch alle gar
nicht unbedingt weiß sein es gibt ja
noch ganz andere leute die sich für
musik interessieren und auch die haben
kapital und das können wir anzapfen also
das ist jetzt keine reine menschenliebe
sondern einfach ein logisches mag denken
dass man den pop allerdings erst sehr
spät entdeckt hatten digitalität hat das
möglich gemacht wenn wir über die
digitalisierung sprechen da müssen wir
über algorithmen sprechen
und ich habe eine frage die die geht im
prinzip vom walkman hin zum algorithmus
von etwas bot iv zum beispiel
der walkman das ist ja eine bekannte
these hat dem dem individualisierung
schub der 80er jahre enorm gutgetan oder
auch schlecht je nachdem wie man sieht
und jetzt ist die frage die frage hat
der walkman mit blick auf die
vereinzelung nicht auch sehr viel
gemeinsam mit streaming dienste wie
spotify schließlich bietet mir der
algorithmus eine ganz individuelle auf
mich zugeschnitten auswahl von
playlisten an und wenn jeder nutzer so
letztlich nur noch auf seine nischen
geschmack zugreift verschwinden die
gemeinsamen nenner ja und das ergebnis
könnten ja präferenz blasen seien aber
man könnte genauso gut anders herum
argumentieren und sagen in allen kneipen
und restaurants laufen durch dieselben
playlisten wir können uns also vor
lauter gemeinsamen nenner kaum noch
retten wie sehen sie das es sind
tatsächlich parallele phänomene aber auf
unterschiedlichen gebieten was jetzt
quasi die blasen theorie angeht naja ich
glaube in den digitalen wissenschaften
ist man sich mittlerweile einig dass die
these von der filter blase von reiser
vor gut zehn jahren vorgestellt nicht
mehr stimmt das wäre ich online er mit
mehr diversität konfrontiert sind als am
alten stammtisch und das genau das uns
ja so sehr aufregt immer wieder und
wütend machen lässt das würde mit sophie
differenz konfrontiert sind und
eigentlich ja gerade nicht mit
ähnlichkeit wenn man so möchte all so
was ähnliches passiert in der musik
natürlich schon auch also einerseits ist
es natürlich eine wunderbare
diversifizierung die irgendwie online
stattfindet aber ich glaube der ganz
großer unterschied zur kultur der
playlist die über den walkman zum
beispiel eingeführt ist es wer diese
playlisten erstellt und nach welche
funktionen sie organisiert sind ich
glaube ich das ist der entscheidende
unterschied
die walkman playlist das mixtape wurde
natürlich immer mit gewissen rezipient
innen im hinterkopf erstellt wir haben
auf ein love interest gesprochen da
wusste sie ganz genau für wen sie das
machen eine sehr individuelle zugang auf
eine person ihre identität vielleicht
auch eine situation sie gesagt haben ich
mache das jetzt für den bunten abend auf
klassenfahrt oder so da kenne ich das
publikum auch mehr oder minder das ist
eine klassische kuratorische leistungen
was heute aber der präferierte container
der playlist ist auf spotify das
sind eigentlich vor allem mut base
playlist das heißt es geht um stimmung
auch das gab es früher kuschelrock gibt
es schon ewig es gab auch immer
komplikationen für das romantische
dinner zu zweit aber es war nie ein
zentraler container das war immer etwas
was an den rändern eben auch noch gab
und diese verschiebungen von etwas
marginalen also die kuratierte playlist
für stimmungsabhängig musik oder music
in den kaufhäusern um unseren aufenthalt
möglichst lange zu verlängern gibt seit
den 50er jahren in amerika ist aber
marginal geblieben von pop ist jetzt ins
zentrum gewandert und das ist schon ein
sehr entscheidender unterschied ob sie
die playlist machen für jemand
bestimmtes oder ob sie eben playlists
tatsächlich machen lassen und musik fast
nur noch so konsumieren das ist
natürlich wirklich etwas wo der künstler
die künstlerin aus position komplett in
den hintergrund tritt quasi die funktion
dass mut based eben das stimmungs
abhängige der playlist in den
vordergrund tritt statt des künstlers
wird musik dabei mittel zum zweck das
war sie natürlich immer schon auch also
popmusik ist eine moderne klassische
kapitalistische waren form wenn man es
mal so ein bisschen maxi ist die scham
ausdrücken möchte sie hatte immer ein
mittel zum zweck ich würde aber sagen
dass diese zweckmäßigkeit eben stark in
den vordergrund rückt und so etwas wie
pop was mich interessiert an diesem
verhältnis das heißt dann wenn die
rezipienten eben wichtig werden quasi im
feedback und die erst dann quasi pop
ermöglichen das tritt mir beim streaming
bisschen in den hintergrund weil
wirklich jemand anderes das umfeld
kontrolliert und das ist eine glaube ich
eine historisch einmalige situation wenn
quasi der plattenladen gleichzeitig das
label ist dass wir auch nie mehr
verlassen also wenn wir streamen bleiben
wir im player und das ist immer die
software nicht unser handy oder den
computer oder das abspielen das ist die
software auf der seite die wir nie mehr
verlassen also das als hätten wir früher
eine platte ein album der marke philips
gekauft dass wir nur auf einen philips
plattenspieler hätten abspielen können
und auch nur in dem laden wo wir das
gekauft haben ist eine sehr drastische
analogie aber es stimmt auf digitale
überschrieben wir verlassen diesen laden
nie mehr unsere beziehung dazu ist
kontinuierlich geworden wir wissen worum
es geht um die abschöpfung der daten der
nutzer daten die länge unserer unseres
aufenthalts des english crawling das
programm des nigers hat wunderbare
seiten meist wirklich den zugang
erleichtert für ganz viele
bevölkerungsschichten die das vorher
nicht haben habe ich auch gesagt dass es
wahnsinnig teuer gewesen quasi ashur zu
bleiben bei pop der nachteil ist
tatsächlich das ständig jemand anders
bestimmt wie wir quasi hören und ich
sehe da aber auch schon erste
gegenbewegung erste signale dass das in
naher zukunft anders sein wird was sind
das für signale es sind zum teil
signale die mit der pandemie zu tun
haben auch mit ökologischen bewusstsein
glaube ich ich glaube zum beispiel das
weltweite tourneen sich schon lange
nicht mehr richtig rechnen für bands für
die sich vor 20 jahren noch gerechnet
hatte das obere mittelfeld dance aus usa
die tausende hallen vielleicht gespielt
haben das rechnete sich eigentlich schon
lange nicht mehr für die um die welt zu
fliegen sie legen dabei drauf hat sie
das sogenannte live wo wir dachten das
würde die verluste aus dem
verschwundenen oder geschmolzenen
tonträgergeschäft ausgleichen der hat
nie stattgefunden das stimmte immer nur
für weltweit ungefähr 50 brands oder
eben bands wenn man so möchte das geht
schon länger zurück dann wird es einfach
auch ökologisch nicht so wahnsinnig
sinnvoll mit einem riesen tross um die
welt zu ziehen und die pandemien seit
bald zwei jahren hat das natürlich noch
mal beschleunigt also das quasi sehr
viele acts aus übersee auch aus england
im übrigen noch erschwert der exit quasi
keine headliner sind auf europäischen
festivals was auch ganz interessant war
also sagen wir auch musiker innen sophie
hunger zb aus der schweiz wo ich
herkomme hat die max ganz interessant
wir haben plötzlich europäische
festivals mit fast nur europäischen acts
und es geht und es ist plötzlich ein
ganz anderes programm wir können so ein
bisschen geschlechtergleichheit
programmieren wir haben mehr europäische
headliner es eigentlich ganz gut und ich
glaube das ist das was ich meine das ist
eine bewegung gibt zu einem vielleicht
kontinentalen nationalen bis hin zu
einem look caren marks an popmusik dass
ich nicht mehr einzig der streaming
organisiert sondern tatsächlich wieder
verstärkt über das live moment das aber
weniger global wird das ist nicht nur
gut also quasi das internationalistische
was ich an pop immer geschätzt habe
trieb damit natürlich auch ein bisschen
in den hintergrund und ich bin jetzt
auch keine der sagen würde man müsse es
aus ökologischen gründen eine deutsch
quote einführen im öffentlich
rechtlichen radio oder so wie das in
frankreich der fall ist ist alles sehr
leid aber es gibt auch sehr viele gute
gründe das quasi abseits des streamings
wieder anders auszurichten
haben sie ein spotify abo ja und wenn es
alle auch dafür und wenn sie spotify
hören stoßen sie dann auch deutlich mehr
neue bands als das vor ihrer spotify
zeit der fall gewesen ist
einerseits ja andererseits langweilt
mich fast alles also wenn ich den
nächster woche oder disco the weekly wie
das heißt auf englisch ich versuche
immer wieder seit 56 jahren seit ich
mich mit spotify immer wieder
beschäftigen journalistisch zumindest
versuche ich es immer wieder das buch zu
finden nach der tat zu gucken was gibt
es da interessant das aber ich glaube
der algorithmus rechnet das immer noch
falsch es geht nicht darum dass die
dinge ähnlich klingen sondern dass sich
überrascht werde die serengeti der
beifahrer quasi also alles womit pop
eben punkten können was nicht so richtig
planbar ist die überraschung auch bei
einem guten dj set ich will ja nicht
quasi immer nur dieselben wie zu hören
was vielfach geschieht in clubs
mittlerweile von den digitalen
programmen unterstützt da geht es
vielleicht noch etwas anderes mal mit
trinken mit seinen freunden will sich
unterhalten in kleinen gruppen
vielleicht weniger ein transformative
erlebnis in der gemeinschaft haben da
haben sich bedürfnisse offenbar
verschoben mich langweilt das aber
musikalisch und dasselbe passiert auch
bei spotify was dazu kommt dass wenn ich
meine aufmerksamkeit quasi auf 2.000
künstler innen pro monat verteile statt
wie bisher vielleicht auch zehn oder
zwanzig ist ja klar was ökonomisch
passiert also wer damit quasi überleben
kann und wer eben nicht aber das tool
alle musik zu wollen dich wird sofort
ins archiv zu steigen wenn ich denke da
kommt eine neue platte ich möchte die
fünf vorher auch noch mal kurz hören
oder einzelne songs daraus zumindest ist
natürlich ein absolut unschlagbar stuhl
von dem viele leute auch in deutschland
übrigens sind eher lang die leute die
den mp3 erfunden haben da hat der
doktorvater von karlheinz brandenburg
dieter seitz schon 1981 davon betreibt
man könnte doch eine zentrale musikbox
erfinden würde die man dann mit
computern zugang hat oder so eine traum
von spotify in franken 1981 geträumten
das ist eine sehr gute sache dass der
mittlerweile erfüllt ist aber es gibt
viele andere dinge die wir einfach
regulieren müssen um sie anders zu
gestalten wo sie gerade mp3 sagen sie
müssen uns unbedingt noch einmal
erzählen was der ja sehr schlecht
beleumundete song wind of change mit dem
mp3 format zu tun hat ach ja die arme
techniker da in erlangen und nürnberg
vom fraunhofer institut oder eben auch
an der uni die haben zu 45 referendums
gehabt an denen sie eben an der
datenreduktion gearbeitet haben das ist
ja mp3 wie kriege ich das digitale fall
so klein dass ich mit sehr wenig
bandbreite damals verschicken kann die
cd hat ja ihre bandbreite dass während
ihrer großen feier gewesen ohne dass das
menschliche ohr das merkt da haben sie
mit psycho akustischen grundsätzen quasi
errechnet was kann ich von diesen pfeil
wegstreichen ohne dass wir sofort merken
und pfeifen und die menschliche stimme
ist sehr gut dafür dass eine referenz
weil war eben tom's diner von zusammen
das andere war das kalken von madoff
technik musste das glaube ich so zwei
jahre lang jeden tag mehrmals klaus
meine in seinem buch pfeifen hören und
der wind of change teuer dass sie immer
auf dem zusammenbruch des
sozialistischen ostens gewünscht wurde
rein inhaltlich hat dann später wenn man
so will tatsächlich zum zusammenbruch
der tonträgerindustrie allerdings erst
zehn jahre später geführt was muss ich
denn eigentlich aus einer feier
wegstreichen oder was kann ich
wegstreichen ohne verluste hinnehmen zu
müssen
sie können zum beispiel nach sehr lauten
schlägen gerade von sehr hohen tönen zum
beispiel am schlagzeug auf eine symbole
und auch sonst einer lauten bass pauke
könnte ich sofort ziemlich viel
wegstreichen weil die quasi alles andere
dann übertönt also da sind wir einfach
zu langsam rein kognitiv dass unser
gehirn die signale verarbeitet hat es
lustig ist aber auch dass selbst die
davor etwas wegstreichen können zum
beispiel und das ist da weil der sehr
laute schall eben einen moment braucht
bis er ihr gehirn erreicht können sie
das vorher auch nicht mehr verarbeiten
wenn der laute schallt das quasi
überschreibt das ist klingt erstmal
ebene also dass sie quasi vor dem lauten
ereignis etwas wegstreichen können aber
das hat eben mit eigentlich zu lange
zeit zu tun die das signal braucht bis
wir das kognitiv erreichen das sind so
zwei grundsätze also vor und nach lauten
show ereignissen können sie fast alles
wegnehmen weil das überschrieben wird
gibt es noch zwei weitere das wird ein
bisschen komplizierter sind damals lose
vier grundsätze und diese forschung gab
es eben in deutschland und die war nicht
übersetzt auf englisch was dem deutschen
forscher-team deutliche vorsprung
verschafft hat diesen standard auch zu
entwickeln zwar an mehrere teams dran
und ging gleich ursprünglich darum einen
neuen audio standard für dvds zu
entwickeln daran dass man jetzt
irgendwie musik weiß machen die per
internet verschickt hatte dann was noch
niemand gedacht dass kam dann quasi erst
später mit der knie für windows 95
den ersten quasi einigermaßen gut
funktionierenden mp3 player entwickelt
hat im letzten moment da noch drauf
geschafft wurde bill gates dachte ja
nicht so richtig ans internet hat lange
nicht daran gebraucht oder jungen co
oder im laden haben ihn irgendwann
erzeugten gesagt wir brauchen ja ein
mp3-player das wird unser asset und so
war es dann auch also windows 95 hat
entscheidend erfolg hat auch damit zu
tun dass da plötzlich in den b 3 player
darauf eine software die das leben
ermöglicht hat hören sie noch
schallplatten
ja und zwar viel stärker als eben in
diesen komischen 90er jahre negativ ja
auch schon gesprochen haben tatsächlich
und das ist glaub hat weniger damit zu
tun dass ich jetzt ein sound fällt die
schießt wäre mein verstärker habe ich
seit 30 jahren mann half dieser
verstärker meine boxen das in vintage
boxen aus
frankreich dich auch schon gebrauch
gekauft hatte sind auch schon seit 20
jahren da das könnte alles ein bisschen
besser sein
was ich aber daran genießen ist
tatsächlich wichtige pressung sind für
gewisse muss ich insbesondere jazz
überhaupt keine rolle spielt meinem buch
zum beispiel aber wie sehr ausmacht in
meinem pop oder musikgeschmack dass man
dann hat sie einer anderen
aufmerksamkeit gezogen wird also man
macht die platte auf der ganze raum hört
dann auch zu dass euch dann nicht auf
kopfhörer die familie verhält sich dazu
die freunde und man lässt erst mal
durchlaufen das kippen und so nervt an
so ein bisschen und wann hört zumindest
mal keine ahnung 23 minuten oder so für
eine seite ein bisschen aufmerksamer zu
und das hat sowas von einem schon fast
wie ein konzert mittlerweile
einfach was wischt auf dem telefon oder
auf dem computer und einer platte so
zukunft bisschen mehr kirche wenn auch
zu hause verraten sie uns zum schluss
noch welche drei alben für die ewigkeit
sie auf welchen geräten am liebsten
hören
versuche listen braucht man ja
mindestens eine woche bis man sie ja
aber das ist jetzt echt schwierig also
ich würde mal mit dem einfachen beginn
und sagen so was ganz spirituelles auch
nicht wirklich originell aber schon
einen meilenstein ist laut sipri und
john coltrane
das habe ich erst auf
kassette geschenkt gekriegt aber dachte
denn das muss ich jetzt eben tatsächlich
auf schwerem vinyl haben um es auch
dementsprechend zu zelebrieren das ist
nicht musik die man eben also als
stimmungs enhancer quasi hört dann muss
man ganz anders zu hören die ich glaube
ich bin auch ein großer techno fan
und zwar sowohl als konsument wir jetzt
auch als tänzer interessiert mich das
nach wie vor sehr und habe mich auch
sehr geprägt
dass ich da fast lieber manchmal die cd
die also einen schlechten leumund hat
mittlerweile höhere war es einfach
technisch ein tatsächlich immer noch
sehr gutes
speichermediums mit sehr gute qualität
was übrigens auch nachhaltiger ist als
ein song oder ein album mehrfach zu
streamen streamen hat auch einen grossen
fußabdruck
da würde ich jetzt eher auf mixtapes
gehen bei techno und nicht auf einzelne
alben ist ja kein albumformat wenn sie
so wollen und was gibt es denn da noch
es gibt da schon so dinge die ich auch
gerne mal auf kopfhörer hören dass
vielleicht weniger das ist vielleicht
auch nicht unbedingt
techno sondern das sind dann wirklich so
ganz massiert hip hop produktion das
können ganz neue sachen seien wie vom
kgb zum beispiel oder so die klassischen
ersten richtig ganz tollen hip hop
produktion von timbaland oder in den
hintern ulla jahren die ihr kürzlich ein
mainstream so einen sound avantgardismus
rein gebracht haben der sehr sehr verein
ist sondern ich überhaupt nicht grob und
auch sehr viel verschiedenen geräten
gleich gut funktioniert aber eben
tatsächlich auch auf dem kopfhörer wenn
ich sowas wie zum beispiel ypsomed von
tweets produziert von timbaland es
glaube ich früher nuller jahre sowas
muss man auf kopfhörer hören um nicht
nur die besser mit zu kriegen sondern
was da auch noch im hintergrund an
großen verein halten passiert
playboy three peat was pop und seine
geräte über uns erzählen es bei hansa
berlin erschienen und kostet 23 euro
tobi müller herzlichen dank danke auch
wie auch schon in der letzten ausgabe
über sachbücher beschließen wir die
heutige folge mit einigen tipps ich habe
drei kollegen gebeten im rahmen einer
portierten kurz empfehlung jeweils ein
sachbuch vorzustellen dass ihnen
besonders gut gefallen hat hier kommen
die ergebnisse
ich bin in sofia dreisbach
politikredakteur in der faz und ich habe
das buch gelesen navalny seine ziele
seine gegner seine zukunft geschrieben
haben dass jan martin baum der franzose
mobile aloe und der brite ben nobel und
erschienen ist es im hoffmann und campe
verlag
das buch ist tatsächlich eine sehr
interessante geschichte sehr detailliert
über russland wohl bekanntesten
oppositionspolitiker spätestens seit dem
anschlag mit naughty dog auf ihnen in
einer knapp überlebt hat und was das
buch so besonders macht ist das eine
wallende über den ja im vergangenen jahr
vor allem sehr sehr viel gesprochen
wurde von dem auch alte geschichten etwa
nationalistische und rassistische
aussagen wieder ausgegraben wurden hier
dermaßen detailliert besprochen wird
auch immer im kontext gesetzt mit der
russischen opposition immer im kontext
gesetzt mit dem kreml und mit der
generell der politischen situation in
russland so dass das buch eine wirkliche
bereicherung ist was den blick auf
navalny angeht
mein name ist maria wiesner ich bin
redakteurin im gesellschaftshaus vor der
faz und ich empfehle dir zadora danken
biografie von michaela k die trägt den
schönen titel lasst uns tanzen und
champagner trinken trotz alledem und ist
erschienen im btb verlag isidor danken
oder quasi die mutter des modernen
tanzes und was michaela karl so einer
guten biografen macht ist dass sie wie
auf einer sehr guten abend party nicht
einfach stur an der gastgeberinnen
hängen bleibt sondern ab und zu kleine
smalltalk wie die netten einstreut also
das heißt man lernt nicht nur sehr sehr
viel über isidora danken und über den
tanz den sie vorangebracht hat und zu
völlig neuen form geführt hat sondern
man lernt sehr sehr viel über das
kalifornien im goldrausch in dem sie
aufgewachsen ist über das belle epoque
paris dass sie dann später gezogen ist
über all die vielen personen zu denen
sie kontakt hatte die affären die sie
hatte mit künstlern aus ihrer zeit eine
sehr runde sehr aufregende figur eine
sehr aufregende biografie die man
besonders momentan in diesen grauen
wochenenden ganz hervorragend durchlesen
kann weil es ist als wenn man selber
auch so sehr exzentrischen party
unterwegs gewesen
ich bin jörg thomann redakteur im
ressort leben der frankfurt einmal ein
sonntagszeitung und ich empfehle ein
buch von jemandem sie kennen dürften
weil eigentlich jeder kennt nämlich von
paul mccartney lyrics heißt dann im ch
beck verlag erschienenes werk was ein
gewaltiges under statement es daher
natürlich nicht nur einfach seine
songtexte abdruckt stattdessen erzählt
mir karten von 154 liter sein leben das
vergnüglich und unseres hand wir
erfahren viel bei mir alis familie über
seine frauen bis auf die eine mit ersten
hässlich entscheidung kam über seinen
freund john lennon und die anderen
beatles ganz selten nur klingt mir
gerade dabei ein wenig gekränkt weil
mein sohn genie mit oder verkannt hat
und weiß bei der entfremdung von ländern
zur verletzung kam insgesamt dadurch
zieht das buch der selber heitere
optimistische grundton d mehr aus der
meistersaison scannt und er gerade
diesen zeiten absolut willkommen ist das
buch macht sie dennoch prima auf dem
gabentisch wenn du dein groß genug ist
zwei bände von 900 seiten in einem
stabilen schuber das ist schon ein
echter klotz am stück müssen das alles
natürlich nicht lesen aber ist
beatles-fan wenn es unbedingt trotzdem
tun
in den charts und auf unserer seite
faz.net / bücher - podcast bücher mit
finden sie hinweise und kritiken zu den
titeln die in dieser folge besprochen
wurden wenn sie fragen oder anmerkungen
haben können sie mir gerne schreiben die
e-mail-adresse lautet bücher - podcast
faz.de bücher mit
natürlich können sie unseren podcast
auch abonieren licon und ihm
applaudieren indem sie ein sternchen
vergeben am zweiten weihnachtsfeiertag
sprechen andrea diener und fridtjof
küchemann an dieser stelle mit ihren
gästen über das lesen zwischen den
jahren die lust am lesen und das
anstiften zur leselust vielen dank fürs
zuhören und bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]